furious passengers disembarked a cruise
ship in England overnight after a 14 day
voyage which they say was scarred by
everything from miss stops to onboard
sewage problems that's never good
the passengers staged mass protests
before the ship docked in Southampton
this morning in response the cruise line
is offering a 25 percent credit toward a
future trip but we're told more than a
thousand people are now just planning to
sue the company mola Lengai reports we
were very very disappointed and we were
not alone passengers leaving the
Norwegian spirit cruise ship this
morning we're quick to share their anger
there's a lot of people that are saying
never again yeah we feel like we've been
scammed the cruise left from the same
port in England on September 27th
passengers paid prices starting around
$1,200 for a 14 day trip that was
supposed to include stops in Holland
Norway Iceland and Ireland but problems
mounted quickly after what Norwegian
called severe weather conditions within
the guidelines of its guest contract the
ship canceled several planned
destination
leaving irate passengers stuck on board
for days the hallways didn't smell very
good
smelled like sewage katachi Jones and
her boyfriend left the cruise early amid
additional concerns over broken plumbing
she says Norwegians response leaves a
bad taste a refund would be nice but a
discount to spend more money with them
is really just not going to cut it for
people for CBS this morning I'm Malou
leggy we've all seen disgruntled
passengers but I've never seen people
like that wait I think she raises a good
point a discount yeah no thanks might
have to do better than that